my next guest has been in exile for two
and a half years fleeing Belarus to
neighboring Lithuania and this week the
Belarusian opposition leader was handed
a 15-year jail term In Absentia for
treason Svetlana
pronounce it for me
is with me here in the studio thank you
so much for joining us we really do
appreciate it you have been sentenced to
15 years in absentia why are you not in
your country tell us what happened in
Belarus uh you know in 2020 we had
Prudential elections it was my husband
who wanted to participate because he was
supported by birth and people but regime
jail team because he did to challenge
18 years now it's already 19 and a half
years wow and I stepped instead of my
husband to show my love to him and to my
country and I was overwhelmingly
supported by Verizon people because
birds and Society want to want changes
in Belarus we for 28 years we have been
lived under dictatorship but we won
Democratic changes in in the country
since after the fraudulent elections
according to
uh independent observers I won the
elections but location consists the
power with the help of violence and I
had to flee Belarus because of
repressions with the children with the
children yeah and after front elections
huge massive protests took place on the
streets of Belarus we wanted peacefully
change this
dictatorship system but with the help of
violence with the help of supports of
Kremlin lucasanka managed to
stay in power and since then for two and
a half years already repressions haven't
stopped for a day in our country every
day
17 20 people are being detained for
their political views and now not only
those who are opposing the regime but
also those who are opposing the war and
supporting Ukraine also became the
enemies of the regime How concerned are
you that talking out means that that
could be detrimental for your husband
you know of course you know people in
Belarus especially those who are in
prisons under constant threats there is
no law in our country and of course
people in prisons are accumulated
constantly physical and morally they're
being tortured but I know that only when
I'm loud when I'm talking about Belarus
telling the world about human rights
abuses in our country about absence of
law this will be the chance to release
all of them and our people in Belarus
and our political prisoners are very
brave people and even being behind the
bars you know they are continuing they
fight they encourage us don't stop don't
think about us think about Belarus and
about our future what is day-to-day life
like for you now and you have a bounty
on your head now 15 years behind bars
um you have to I think you're living in
Lithuania at the moment what is
day-to-day life like for you and the
children
uh so first of all I have to say that
this sentence uh you know doesn't mean
anything for me uh because it has
nothing to uh deal with Justice uh I
know that I have to uh continue the work
we are doing to advocate for Belarus to
show the world uh you know humanitarian
catastrophe in our country and uh you
know I I try to spend as much time as
possible in Lithuania you know seeing my
children uh communicating with Bill
russens who are in Lithuanian Poland and
in Belarus but of course a huge part of
my job is to communicate with the
political leaders of different countries
uh explaining what's going on in the
country how bills is connected with the
war in Ukraine to attract attention to
our humanitarian problems and to raise
awareness actually to show how Builders
is important important for regional
security because now I say that bills is
a little bit overlooked uh because you
know the war in Ukraine but bills is
part of this crisis and you and the war
cannot be over until Belarus is free
what would you say to look a Shankar if
you could speak to him now I have
nothing to say to him but I'm sure that
he understands that those in society
will never accept him anymore and it's
the best chance for him to live uh
peacefully live and to let Belarus to
develop uh in the European way when do
you think you might be able to go home
difficult to say I
I will nobody will say you know the
concrete
term you know when when we will win uh
this fight but what I know is that every
day I have to fight against dictatorship
to do something that will bring this
Victory closer okay what do you want the
British government do to do to help you
so first of all I have to say that UK
has already done so much for a person uh
people for the Russian Civil Society and
to create multiple points of pressure on
the regime
if I you know I was here one year ago
and now I say that Belarus is as I said
is uh overlooked because attention span
is rather short and I have to uh remind
uh the UK government in Parliament about
Belarus though since 2020 this you know
assistance
regime has never stopped but this
assistant's a little bit chaotic so uh
we need more systematic approach and I
see
eagerness to help us to be with the bill
russens and but I asked for example to
synchronize all the sanctions against
the regime with the European Union to
increase assistance to our media to our
human rights defendant centers
to stand solidarity with theirs it's
very important because I uh when I see
that person people feel that they are
forgotten they are abandoned they lose
this energy to continue this fight now
it's on the top but we need the world
attention let's go to talk Jay thank you
for taking the opportunity to come and
join us and hopefully people will be
listening to what you have to say thank
you very much Cindy good to see you
thank you